Doug Gottlieb was listening of course
the former college basketball player at
Oklahoma State and has his own show on
Fox Sports Radio and Doug wanted to
weigh in with this topic Doug what do
you have for me this morning yeah I mean
like the the crazy part about the Pitino
story is I could easily make the
argument that's the he's the best
basketball coach in college basketball
in the modern era okay I mean think
about how innovative he was when he was
at Providence and then with the Knicks
he embraced a three-point shot for
anybody else three I mean you go back
and you look at those Knicks teams and
they were pressing and shooting threes
booked way before was in vogue in the
NBA to do so yeah but nobody's
questioning his ability to coach no no
I'm not either but I think it's going to
be an amazing tale to tell
you know maybe in ten years how much of
how this thing ended overshadows all of
the incredible good or or the
innovations that he said he's not going
to be he's a Hall of Fame coach for the
couple national championships and yet
considering the prostitution thing and
now this it ends in shame and like like
rightfully so up but what I would point
out to yet pak40 on earlier and part of
it is he lives in Kentucky and so while
this may be status quo in the state of
Kentucky I don't believe this happens
everywhere matter of fact I know for a
fact it doesn't happen everywhere and I
think the percentage is far far lower
and I actually think this is a good
cleanse and you know it's like I talked
to a couple code my brother's an
assistant coach Oregon State he's like
not only now do we not have do we do we
not cheat and we don't but when people
ask us for stuff the great thing about
the FBI coming in is we can say dude I
don't want to get arrested so I don't
need anything but I don't think it
happens everywhere and I think the
reason that that Nike is now in the
crosshairs is because one of the guys
who was arrested is a guy named moral
code and he was fired from Nike but he
ran their grassroots operation up until
a year ago and so now how much
information is he turned over and so yes
so people become very very nervous but I
don't think as many schools will be
implicated as as the common fan thinks
there are plenty of schools that do it
the right way and those ones are not
only sleeping good at night but this is
it this is a chance to kind of clean up
the college basketball game more than
aids in the grassroots possibly yeah but
you have you're saying well it's not
going to be everybody I got Arizona
number-one team in the country I got USC
at top ten teen Oklahoma State top ten
team University of Miami Louisville is a
top ten team these are all the good
teams and they're doing it I would think
if you're not a good team you would be
doing this these are the guys who are
already good and have good teams explain
that well that's that's the part that
doesn't make sense don't a thing it
doesn't it doesn't make sense from from
this perspective you know like I think
that there's an assumption that Kentucky
Kentucky's got to be doing this sort of
stuff and and Duke's got to be doing
this stuff whereas if you if you know
how maybe when they fill in those
coaches first get there in order to
first get a player or two to jumpstart
their program but once you have it
rolling here at Kentucky you tell a kid
don't take money now why would shake
mine now all you got to do is wait nine
months and you're gonna get paid way
more money than we could ever possibly
give you it doesn't ruin your reputation
doesn't ruin our ability to play in the
NCAA tournament that's why I think this
happens less than you think
I look I do think there's a 10 percent
of kids that have their hands out but
everybody kind of knows who those kids
are and once you have your program
rolling you don't need to do it but why
do this though Doug you're talking about
maybe the best college basketball coach
in America his program is rolling he's
on scholarship he survived this stripper
situation why are you paying players
yeah well but first of all Louisville is
not Kentucky you know and what's crazy
about it is well nobody in Kentucky no
no but they're not obviously it's you
know if you you know you take a bite of
that Apple you're like well we wait we
can get a top-20 kid we get a top-20
credit and all we got to do is let you
know wash our hands of it we didn't pay
him
adidas paid him I think it's the
enticement of one last run you know make
one last run a national championship and
then call it a call it a career and I
probably think that's
that's probably how he always does it
there I mean the the difference here is
if you read the if you read the
indictment there's coach - if he's
coached - who had direct knowledge that
this was going on Louisville is going to
be punished far more severely than if he
had plausible deniability and the only
reason he was fired was because as you
pointed out when he started your show
Dan like at some point enough Sanaa
enough bad publicity for Louisville they
have the rights that they can show cause
and fire him why do it I mean I think
obviously because you get greedy about
winning and you think if I can just get
one more top-level kid all of a sudden
that energizes my program and recruiting
you didn't have to though you just he
could have simply recruited guys that
going to play four in five years won a
national championship at Louisville be
super competitive but but maybe not win
the whole thing and obviously this is
what greed does to you Doug we
appreciate calling in thank you good
night
Doug Gottlieb Fox Sports Radio the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience